[Musik]
ja ja ich möchte ja nicht zu viel
verraten aber die frau bekommt am ende
ihren prinzen und ich habe gedacht dem
autor fällt etwas besseres ein leider
nicht da habe ich mich zu ihnen setzen
weil die kneipe voll ist
ich esse nicht gern allein eine gute
mahlzeit ist eine mahlzeit die man mit
anderen netten menschen an einem tisch
ist
bitte danke
mein name ist übrigens jacques freut
mich sehr
machen sie auch den ausflug in ein ich
bin auf der durchreise
man kann sagen dass ich hier arbeite ich
teste deutsche gaststätten
sie testen deutsche restaurants für wen
arbeiten sie fürs fernsehen ein
nein ich besitze drei restaurants in
frankreich und jetzt möchte ich auch in
deutschland ein restaurant eröffnen
aber naja die typischen deutschen
gerichte sind immer so einfach
bratwurst currywurst alles immer mit
wurst wissen sie dinge ich koche gern
und für mich ist ein gutes essen essen
das wirklich lecker ist es darf ruhig
ein bisschen raffiniert sein
das stimme ich ihnen zu aber es stimmt
nicht dass wir hier in deutschland immer
nur wurst essen die franzosen essen ja
auch nicht immer nur baguette oder das
stimmt natürlich aber meine restaurants
sind etwas für feinschmecker meine
köchin die köche sollten menschen sein
die innovativ sind sind sie eine
feinschmeckerin liegen
ich weiß nicht ich denke ja ich bin mir
sicher sie haben ein tollen geschmack
als sollen wir bestellen